[Musique]
vous ne verrez que ça ce soir sur france
3 dans le village préféré des français
de belles images de sang s'est retournée
en automne la petite ville mondialement
connue pour son appellation passe à la
vitesse supérieure
devenir un grand cru télévisuelle
c'est chouette c'est une belle promotion
pour le village de sancerre ça nous fait
ça nous fait une pub à un niveau
national ça assez chouette ray un moment
que les sources est roi prépare sur la
place du village sur grand écran avec
des photos dans la rue c'est très
important pour nous parce qu'elle ça va
nous permettre de faire connaître notre
joli visage
donc oui on attend avec impatience la
diffusion ce soir et peut-être d'être
élu village préféré des français
un moment festif important pour la
mairie qui compte sur cette visibilité
nationale
aujourd'hui ça va être une nouvelle une
nouvelle fête
j'espère nous ça fait très longtemps
qu'on n'a pas eu d'événements
fédérateurs sur notre village donc
là c'est vraiment l'occasion pour le
faire et se retrouver tous ensemble
toutes les générations
ce soir si vous ne pouvez pas venir sur
la place tous devant france 3 venez
découvrir s'en sert sans aucune
modération